I think my goal is to break 2,500 what's
my rating 24:59 okay well I can't play
the England but I can play e4 and see
what happens
d5 let's play the Scandinavian what is
this I have a thing against this I think
I remember like Bishop d2 just some
solid approach to play Bishop f4 early
I'm not playing a gambit well I could
play the Tennyson gambit
I forgot about the thymus and gambits
save that for next time okay this looks
reasonable let's still have some kind of
sharp interesting position are we both
going to Castle queenside maybe maybe
knocks always taking b1 ooh scary
a3 maybe Bishop d3 I'm just gonna go for
trades this is gonna be a positional
game maybe unless it got shark oh wow oh
it's getting shark but not in my favor
can i boat as gambits but what does
gambit I'm it doesn't quite work though
because my bishop hangs in the end I
really want to go test gambit it doesn't
work but what else do I do
this is such I just forgot about 95 this
is really bad
ship c7 does that work
okay I don't know to do here takes let's
try taking a chance I'll lose a lot of
material I'm gonna have to bow ties
Gannett actually I think this is the
best way to do it I'll have two pieces
to my race for the Queen
hopefully yeah it's Queen and pawn for
two bishops go test I'll I'll try and if
like that
DG or no thanks for Southern mmm c3 just
trying to be solid I need time to be on
my side but it's not on my side on down
a minute before coming
Bishop c1 no I mean 95 trying to be
aggressive maybe see for now c4 there
there this is really dangerous
after this moved to let's play nice e4
maybe there's some hope still left fiend
covering the night trying to chase the
Queen away just go away
take this oh is that a bad move maybe
probably Oh doesn't take okay let's play
might cod4 is hanging play rook c4 still
not pleasant and take that maybe 26
seconds and it send some nerves for my
opponent just based on the moves and
take this let's see - probably a six I
wanna play have to take this there goes
something wait that was a free queen why
do you play each six why do you play age
six
I was a free queen I was not expecting
that oh that's annoying could be my twin
right they're still alive though kind of
can't trust the tree moves jeez hang a
queen again please yes still a fight
though no yes
let's go let's go the boat s gambit has
paid off
thanks Bo tez what a game
I think aim points no zero zero zero
0.33 what again shaking from vacuum
people watching in the future on YouTube
hope you enjoy this I'll see you with
more content shortly goodbye